haben den bogen schlagen von beginn der
sendung über diesen schrecklichen krieg
die folgen die auch sie sozusagen
behandeln müssen in ihrem
bundesgesundheitsministerium natürlich
haben sie zu kämpfen mit der aktuellen
flüchtlings lage mit hunderttausenden
die kommen wahrscheinlich werden ist
über eine million menschen seien
deutlich mehr die nach deutschland auch
kommen viele von ihnen sind ungeimpft
oder können das zumindest nicht
nachweisen völlig klar in den
kriegswirren und möglicherweise ohnehin
völlig klar macht ihnen das sorgen macht
mir sorgen ganz genau und das ist auch
ein thema unserer
gesundheitsministerkonferenz morgen wir
werden darüber reden wie wir also die
gesundheitliche versorgung der menschen
die aus der ukraine zu uns geflohen sind
darstellen können dazu zählen auch die
impfungen aber werden wir auch prüfen
welche rolle die impfzentren für die
impfung der geflüchteten menschen
leisten können das ist ein wichtiges
thema also ein schnell programm zum
beispiel wäre wäre denkbar wäre möglich
daran arbeiten wir wird darüber
nachgedacht
hier geht es ja nicht nur um die krone
impfung sondern hier sind riesige im
flug und auch für andere impfungen und
da versuchen wir an weg zu finden wie
wir möglichst unbürokratisch und schnell
diese wichtigen im flecken schließen
können in der tat wir reden nicht nur
über corona impfung auch ganz wesentlich
über masernimpfungen natürlich das ist
zugangsvoraussetzung in der kita in der
schule das stellt im moment ganz viele
die dort in der leitung sind
beispielsweise auch vorgang schwierige
moralische entscheidungen man möchte
diese menschen gerne in die kita gruppe
aufnehmen die schule aufnehmen aber man
darf es einfach nicht weil der masern
nachweis hier das fehlt wir haben sie
damit um also wir arbeiten an ich gehe
mit den dingen immer gleich um also wenn
sich bei mir ein problem
meldet
gehe ich sofort an die arbeit und das
haben wir auch getan und hier arbeiten
wir also mit den gesundheitsministern
der länder nach einem vorschlag sind
schon da hat ja erst mal sagen als das
gleiche aber ich bleibe dann muss noch
genauer werden also schon vor etwa zwei
wochen habe ich also in meinem
ministerium eine arbeitsgruppe gegründet
unter leitung von
dr teilchen und gar nicht
sagen ich will nur für die kita leitung
oder in den schulleiter einmal wissen
wie soll der jetzt handelt sollte erst
mal sagen kommt gar nicht infrage ich
nehme die kinder erstmal nicht auf weil
die haben keinen master nachweis das ist
ja die die rechtliche grundlage genau so
eben wie bei einem
infektionsschutzgesetz natürlich kann
also hier nicht gegen das recht
verstoßen werde das recht sagte wir
haben eine maß an impfnachweis licht und
daher also ist das problem hatte ich
aber ich will nur den einen punkt noch
sagen ich war mir das wichtig ist also
ich versuche einfach wenn ein problem da
ist er sofort an lösungen zu gehen und
hier haben wir schon also eine
arbeitsgruppe unter leitung von also
fordert aber auch früher die leiterin
des öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
deutschlandweit habe ich eingestellt
ganz tolle frau und mitarbeiterin und
die arbeitet in mit ihrem team bei mir
im haus an einer lösung dieses problems
es geht nicht aber es geht nicht also
sofort aber wir sind da schon ziemlich
weit und wir werden darüber morgen mit
den gesundheitsministern der länder
sprechen verstanden stand jetzt ist aber
kinder aus der ukraine die kein masern
nachweis impfnachweis haben die bleiben
draußen ersten wir werden nicht eine
deutsche schule eine deutsche kita ob
wir da eine pragmatische lösung finden
das wird sich zeigen das wird sich
zeigen ob wir da mit einer
ausnahmeregelung arbeiten können wir
müssen mal schauen dazu gehört unter
anderem dass wir uns ein bild davon
machen also wie weit verbreitet sind
eigentlich man jetzt bei den kindern die
kommen aber ich glaube wir können das
problem einfach anders wir müssen die
kinder aber auch die erwachsenen hier
sehr schnell nach hinten und daran
arbeiten wir mit hochdruck gesagt die
arbeitsgruppe ist schon anderthalb
wochen in aber dass ich ganz so simpel
weil es ist so dass also die sie müssen
überlegen wo wird geimpft dort wo die
leute ankommen dort wo sie dann hin
kommen usw man weiß ja gerne alle da
sind die länder zuständig stadt ich habe
hier in also im bahnhof habe ich die
ankommt aber ich das einkaufszentrum
besucht hat mir da ein bild gemacht mit
übersetzern mittel menschen gesprochen
habe versucht mir einen überblick
verschaffen was ob dort überhaupt wissen
ob sie selbst oder ihre kinder geimpft
sind das war zum teil nicht der fall die
wussten gar nicht ob sie geben sind
somit da kommen viele probleme zusammen
aber
probleme sind für die ca da um gelöst zu
werden
bin ich rüber gehend ist natürlich die
kita leiterin der schulleiter damit
alleine der steht jetzt natürlich hat er
das recht vor augen aber er steht auch
von der gewaltigen moralischen frage und
muss das vorübergehend selbst für sich
lösen genauso aber er kann aber er kann
daher die kita-leiterin kann daher aber
dankbar dafür sein dass bund und länder
schon schnellstmöglich von samana
problem zu lösen